welcome to free pilot training if you're
struggling with learning how to use vors
you will understand them after this
video or you'll get your money back from
this training
i thought this is free pilot training
exactly
vors are confusing for everyone when we
first start training to be pilots and a
lot of instructors make things worse
when they pass out these little drawings
that might help you out on the written
test but make it more confusing when you
get in the airplane but if i can get you
to understand just a few basic things
you'll see just how easy these vors are
to use and that you don't need these
stupid drawings the first one of these
basic things is the difference in
heading and bearing these are two
different things when we talk about
bearing that's my position in relation
to the position of something else for
example let's say i wanted to identify
my position off this vor and my
airplane's down here now let's say if i
want to fly to the station i have to fly
a course of 300 and that's a west
northwest course 300 is my bearing to
the station and it doesn't matter what
my heading is the heading of my airplane
could be turned all the way in the
opposite direction and my bearing to the
station would still be 300 degrees and
that's because that's the course i need
to fly in order to go to the station
with that in mind sometimes you'll need
to know your bearing from the station if
someone else had to fly from the station
to your position what course would they
fly in this example the course from the
station to my position is one two zero
so that's my bearing from the station
and once again it does not matter what
your heading is it's the course that you
would fly from the station to your
position okay so why am i telling you
all this
vors only get bearing to and from the
station they don't have anything to do
with heading whatsoever and
understanding that is the first step in
making vors easy to use vor stands for
vhf omnidirectional range and that vhf
stands for very high frequency radio and
that just means these things operate off
of radio waves and we use the navid
radios in the plane to pick up that
signal from the vors and in most planes
you tune these in just like you would
the com radios meaning the radios we
talk on so the first step in using a vor
is to tune the frequency in on the nav
aid radios
so today my frequency over here at
bartlesville
is uh 117.9
so i'll tune that in right here
117.9 on the nav aid radios
117.9 and then i'll switch it over here
to the active frequency
on this particular aircraft this navaid
radio is tied to this
vor
right here and this navaid radio is
tied into this one
now that we've tuned in the frequency we
can make sure that we're on the right
frequency one of two ways every vor is
coded with a three letter identifier as
you can see here this one is bravo
victor oscar on some newer aircraft when
you tune the frequency incorrectly these
letters will also be displayed on older
aircraft like mine you can actually turn
the sound on on your navid radios and
listen to this morse code identifier
right here now i'm not saying that you
need to learn morse code all i'm saying
is that this is a great way to make sure
that you're getting the right signal
okay so now let's talk about how these
vors work for just a second these guys
broadcast radio signals all the way
around the station and these radio
signals are aligned with magnetic
courses from the station we call these
individual radio signals radials and
there's 360 of them to match the 360
degrees on a compass
sorry i'm not going to draw all 360 of
them for you here i don't like you guys
that much all right pop quiz time let's
say i'm flying my cessna 172 out here
and i'm on top of the zero seven zero
radial what's my bearing from the
station remember we said that these
radials are aligned with magnetic
courses from the station so that would
mean our bearing is zero seven zero from
the station and now you're starting to
see just how easy this is but now comes
the part that instructors don't explain
too well and because of that everyone
has a hard time with these things all
these radials only broadcast from the
station none of these radials broadcast
to the station
because of that if i'm out here on the
zero nine zero radial from the station i
can't use this radial to fly to the
station i would have to pick one of
these radials on the other side of the
station and use that signal to fly to
the station and if you tune those
radials in on the other side of the
station your airplane will actually
sense those radials on the side you're
on as well and i'm going to simplify
this even more for you in a second but
for now i've got a memory aid for you to
go to the station you must go through
the station and what i mean by that is
to go through the station to a radio on
the other side and this memory aid can
also be used to help you find your
bearing to the station for example if
i'm out here on the zero six zero radial
the radial on the opposite end of the
station is two four zero for my bearing
to this station i went through the
station to two four zero and it's really
easy to come up with those reciprocals
by either adding or subtracting 180 or
just simply looking at the other side of
your compass card all right so now let's
take a look at the two from indicator
we're going to use this guy to determine
whether the course we selected is going
to take us to the station or from the
station and to select a specific course
we can rotate this obs knob on the
course deviation indicator or the cdi
okay so let's say i'm flying somewhere
east of the station and i dial in the
zero nine zero radial would i get a two
or a from indication the answer is
you'll get a from indication and that's
because if you intercept and fly any of
these radials on your side of the vor
they'll take you away from the station
in fact if you're within 90 degrees of
that radial you have selected you will
always get a from indication so that
from indicator not only allows you to
fly a course from the station but you
can also find your bearing from the
station let's say i have the 110 radial
dialed in if i'm receiving a from
indication and my cdi needle is centered
then i know for a 100 fact that i'm on
the 1 1 0 radial now don't worry we'll
talk a little bit more about the needle
here in just a second now let's say i'm
over here on the west side of the
station and i spin the 090 course back
in my cdi in this example i should
expect a 2 indication remember how i
said earlier that there are no radials
going to the station if i want to get a
2 indication on my cdi i have to go
through the station to those radials on
the other side and like i said before my
airplane is actually going to be able to
sense these radials on my side of this
station and that's going to allow me to
intercept that 090 course inbound before
i fly over the station then proceed
outbound the technical wording here is
that the course i've selected will take
me to the station and if you noticed as
soon as we crossed over the station the
indicator flipped and is now giving us a
from indication and that's because we're
on the same side of the station as that
zero nine zero radial and the course
we've selected is now taking us from the
station now here's something kind of
weird that happens sometimes let's say
i've dialed in a course of one eight
what would happen if i'm on a radial
exactly 90 degrees off of the course i
have selected before you answer that
question i want you to think about
something is this course i have selected
gonna take me to the station or from the
station well the airplane thinks you're
exactly in the middle of both
indications so what it gives you is
something called the neutral flag some
older cdi's don't have a neutral flag
they just don't display a to or from
indication but anytime you get this
indication that means you're exactly 90
degrees off the radio you have selected
but if i'm 90 degrees off the radio i
have selected am i right here or am i
over here and this brings us into a
discussion on the cdi needle and you're
going to be amazed at how easy this is
to understand to do that let's take a
closer look at the course deviation
indicator when you use these cdi's you
should imagine your airplane being right
in the center of these things then the
course you want to fly is the white
needle and as you can see from this
example the needle is displaced to the
left that means i'm right of course
in this example i'm left of course
because the needle is displaced to the
right of my position now here's why
everyone always gets confused with these
things in this example i've got the 210
radial dialed in and as you can see i've
got a 2 indication so that means i'm
somewhere back here on the other side of
the station and now you're probably
thinking well this needle doesn't make
any sense according to what you just
told me i should be on the left side of
this line
but i'm actually on the right side
what's the deal here remember what i
told you earlier vors have nothing to do
with heading and your cdi doesn't know
your heading all it knows is that you
put a 2 1 0 course in there and that
radio only goes one direction so in
order for that cdi needle to be accurate
you need to turn your aircraft and point
it in the same direction that that
radial is traveling if you're not able
to turn the airplane for one reason or
another or you're doing this on the
written test just imagine your airplane
turning to the correct heading and
that's going to make this super easy
because if you're out here trucking in
the opposite direction that you have
this radial set this cdi needle is going
to work backwards and we call this
reverse sensing let's look at another
one of these
let's say i still have the two one zero
radial set but now i'm getting a from
indication okay so with the from
indication i know i'm on the same side
of the vor as this radial now let's
imagine our airplane on a 210 heading
and it looks to me like we're right of
course so let's move this airplane over
to the right and now we have a pretty
good idea of where we are
and now i know that if i want to get
back on my 210 course i just have to
turn left a little bit and intercept
that radial let's look at another cdi
that's not giving us a 2 or from
indication as we said before this is
giving a neutral indication and that
just means we're exactly 90 degrees from
the radial we have selected on this
particular cdi i have the zero three
zero radial selected so am i over here
or am i down here
just remember what i said to do turn
your airplane and put it on a heading
that matches the course on the cdi once
you do that it'll be obvious that this
airplane down here is you and that's
because the needle is displaced to the
left just like the course you want to
fly
now let's take a look at how you're
going to get asked some of these
questions on the written test and we'll
look at some examples in the airplane
what's my bearing from the topeka vortac
if my cdi looks like this well i can see
that i have the 030 core selected and
i'm also getting a from indication and
because my cdi is centered i know that
i'm exactly on the zero three zero
radial so let's grab our plotter and
draw a line straight from the vortec
through the zero three zero radial and
now we know for sure that we're
somewhere on this red line now they're
going to try to trip you up with this
question if you're getting this cdi
reading what radial are you on well as
you can see this cdi is giving us a two
indication when we really need a from
indication in order to know the radial
that we're on and because of that the
radial that we're on is on the opposite
side of this two indication so oddly
enough we're still on the zero three
zero radial in this example but if i
want to get a from indication all i have
to do is spin this obs knob all the way
around until the zero three zero course
is at the top of the cdi all right guys
here's another hard one which one of
these airplanes am i in if this is the
indication i'm getting all right so i've
got the 210 radial selected and i'm
getting a two indication and if i want
to go to the station i need to go
through the station to those radials on
the other side so right now both these
airplanes are on the correct side of the
station let's go ahead and imagine both
of these on a two one zero heading then
we'll go ahead and draw our two one zero
course inbound and as you can see the
needle is displaced to the left so this
airplane right here is the obvious
choice let's go play around with these
in the airplane a little bit now
all right so the first thing we're going
to do is where we're going to we're
going to see where we are from the
station
so in order to do that we need to get a
from indication
as you can see here i've got a two
indication
so we need to get a from indication so
we'll spin us around
[Applause]
and if you look at the view if you look
at the vr sectional you'll see that
we're approximately east southeast from
the station so let's put that in the vor
and see what that gives us
[Applause]
there it is now we'll just center up the
needle
so as you can see here
we are on the one one zero radial
roughly from the station
[Applause]
okay
so that's the radio we are on from the
station
real quick i just want to point out that
mike's actually flying a heading of
about 280 right now and that's actually
the opposite direction of the course we
have selected and because of that our
cdi is actually reverse sensing here
so in order to get the cdi needle to
give us good left to right indications
we need to either turn around and fly a
course of 295 here or we need to dial in
a two indication
in this case we're to the left
of our course
[Applause]
in this case we're to the right of our
course
[Applause]
now if i want to go to the station
i need to go through the station
so i'll put this on the other side
[Applause]
so it should be the reciprocal of that
and you can just go slow until you get a
two indication
[Applause]
yeah i hear you now round clear
so now
[Applause]
that will take us to the station
go ahead fly 290 for me
all right so now
if we were in zero win situation
then uh we would be going directly to
the station
and from now we could just fly this
course and follow our white line
if the white line deflects to the left
there that means we're right of course
if the white line deflects to the right
that means we're left of course and so
we're just trying to keep this centered
the heading we're flying is going to be
all depending
on our wind direction
next let's look at how we can use two
vors to find our exact position on a
sectional we call this triangulating our
position pick one of the stations and
find your bearing from the station in
this example once again it looks like
i'm on the zero three zero radial from
the station now that you know that turn
and fly the zero three zero course
outbound this is going to allow you to
stay on that radial and make this more
accurate then let's tune in another bor
that's close by and get our bearing from
that station let's say we're getting a
275 from the station now we know exactly
where we're at and now you can pull out
your plotter or that stupid little scale
on the faa's exam and find out exactly
how far you are from the nearest field
now i'll show you how i do this in the
airplane using foreflight
all right so first thing we're going to
do here is we're going to get a from
indication
[Applause]
so we just spin it around
and i know i'm east of the station so
i'm just going to spin it spin it spin
it until we get a from indication and
i'm going to line it up once we line it
up we're going to go ahead and turn and
fly that heading go ahead and turn and
fly us on a
[Applause]
be like a 105 heading
mike's got us in a turn here
[Applause]
and you can see we're getting off course
a little bit but that's because
we're uh making a turn right now
we'll combat that here in just a second
[Applause]
zero five yeah one zero five so
somewhere in there roll out and you can
see that we're slightly right of course
and that's because we made a left turn
around our course now there so now if he
just gets a little bit left he can
intercept that course
now we can use this other vor to
triangulate our position off of
[Applause]
i'm going to use the tulsa view or
114.4
all right so now i'm going to tune in
the tulsa video
down for 170. slap that in there
and you can see i'm getting a from
indication here and i know i'm like
northeast of the station
i'm just going to spin this other guy
until i triangulate our position here
and mike's doing a good job of keeping
us centered on this from indication here
so now
i've triangulated our position
we're on a 105 from the bartlesville
station
and then we're on a
[Applause]
0-2-5
from this station right here the tulsa
station
and now we know exactly where we are and
that's how easy it is to find your exact
position by using two vors but what if
my equipment's not working properly how
would i know there's actually a few ways
you can test your equipment but one in
particular they're probably going to ask
you about on the written exam
this is the vot which stands for very
high frequency omni test
these things work almost exactly like a
vor they also broadcast radials all the
way around the station with one minor
difference no matter what your bearing
is from the station these radials are
all three six zero radials so no matter
where my airplane is what would happen
if i dialed in a three six zero course
you're absolutely right you would get a
from indication
then if we dialed in the reciprocal
which is 180 then what would we get you
guessed it we'd get a two indication
usually you'll find these close to
bigger airports and if you want to know
the frequency you just have to check in
the chart supplement looks like tulsa
international has one and i could use
that by tuning in the frequency 109.00
thanks for joining me today on free
pilot training if you learned something
from this video that's awesome but don't
quit with this video try this video
you've got some tests coming up
[Music]
position